Now there's one more thing I
want to add to our diagram and
that's something to represent
the idea of multiplicity.
In object diagrams,
multiplicity is just a fancy word for
the number of objects
represented in a relationship.
This is another one of those things
that we're borrowing from UML.
Now multiplicity goes hand and
hand with the contains relationships.
If we look back at the world object,
let's ask ourselves some
how many questions.
For example,
how many actors are in the world, or
how many backgrounds are in a world?
You might say for every world we have
what looks like, could be, many actors,
or for every world we
might have one background.
And conventionally we use terms like
one to many, or many to many, or
even many to one to
represent this multiplicity.
So right now if we
think about the actors,
we can see that there's two actors on
the screen, but there could be more or
there could be worlds where
there's no actors at all.
To be honest, we don't really know.
So we could do two things here, since
we already have the app built, we could
play around with it some more and find
out what are all the different cases for
the number of actors in a world.
Or for what would be the case if
we're designing this from scratch and
we didn't have the app already, we could
just make a decision and go with it.
For instance, we could say for any given
world there may be one to many actors.
We don't know how many,
there could be a lot,
there could be a little,
doesn't really matter.
We could limit it.
We could say for any one world there's
only ever going to be two actors.
But I have a little bit of
an advantage because I already know
that there could be one to
many actors in a world.
And if we go back to our diagram,
we can add the multiplicity to this
contains relationship for actors.
And if we read the multiplicity from
left to right, it follows the same order
as our arrows, so for every one world
we have, we can have many actors.
Now let's look at another example,
this one'll be for
the contains relationship for
the background.
>From what we saw there's only
one background for the world, so
that means this relationship is 1-to-1.
For every one world object
there's one background.
The use of the 1-to-M and the 1-to-1,
this is another thing that
we're taking from UML.
So again, this is kind of a blend of
both a formal and a informal process.
There's something else that
I want to point out and
that is that the relationships
themselves and even the multiplicity
can go in different directions, and
these arrows could be bidirectional.
For example, right now the world
contains 1-to-M actors, but
you may want an arrow going from
actor to world that says for
every one actor,
it could live in many different worlds.
If it were the case that in
the game an actor might show up in
multiple different worlds.
It's really up to you.
You could build these diagrams
however you want, but
these are just some really
popular conventions.
And if you stick close to these
conventions, then it makes it easier for
you to share your diagrams with others.
It also makes it easier to take this
diagram and actually start writing code.
And that's why there are the formal
processes like UML in place because it
makes it easier to go from something
like UML to code, or historically has.
There's one other key takeaway
that I want you to leave with and
that is that you should use a process
for creating object diagrams
that's the least restrictive
to you getting your work done.
I mean, you could spend an entire day,
or weeks, designing an object diagram,
but if it doesn't get you any
closer to a functioning app,
then you might just
be wasting your time.
But there's also great benefit of having
some kind of structure in mind before
you build it.
As a developer,
you'll discover what works best for you.
Some people like to spend five
minutes on an object diagram,
others could spend an entire week.
And another thing is,
if you're working with a team,
a good object diagram
could be a great way for
the whole team to work together to
understand a really complex system.
All right, I'm going to go ahead and
wrap things up here.
But if you're interested, here's our
final diagram for the Alien Adventure,
so take some time to look at it, and
maybe you have a better idea
how to organize things.
Anyways, I hope this was helpful, and
I encourage you to reach out to us, or
to your peers if you
still have questions.